almost 700 kilometers lie between Karlsruhe and Berlin
and between the previous life of Zuikart and the
political enterprise in the capital
lie worlds.
I grew up here in this Vettel,
so n bit behind it.
don't know.
500 meters as the crow flies was my elementary school.
I have lived there so 500 uh
meters as the crow flies to college.
Zoe Cut is a self made millionaire,
was with
rich in software and now invests in startups.
his colleague Alexander Raket is also in the bsw.
they are both well occupied with that.
even at lunch.
how many mails and message were there now
in the last 2 hours?
when we go to when we still take messages in,
then it was certainly 100.
ha ha ha.
I'm also often into CC as a treasurer.
that is already frequency on my life.
instead of enjoying life
does.
zoeke now has 16 hours of days on.
in the past,
he advocated higher entry-level taxes.
he was never in a party.
then he hears about Wagenknecht's plans
and makes 1 meeting off.
Oscar la Fontänen was there too and uh,
we have even imagined
and um we have each other very quickly
very well understood
and um.
i actually have for me too
get confirmed,
that mine is what has been attributed to her.
just not so is because of
Ego Trip or it's all about them.
quite the opposite.
and um
it was very sympathetic and and also good meeting.
that was more than a year ago
in the time after.
zoekat acts in the background
to advance the political restart?
Long will
Wagenknecht all questions about a party foundation AB.
only in the fall of 23 she lets the cat out of the bag.
allegedly
was under Neymar Suikad 1 important puzzle piece at
their decision.
I am not the organizational talent,
so i am not today either
and that's why I need support there.
and it is of course quite existential for me,
that I then also
yes have the peace to know,
there are really competent people with us,
who take care of the other.
that which I am not good at,
that where I also really
yes where I can't get much involved either.
and is the political business harder than you thought?
it is in any case
completely different from the entrepreneurial business.
yes one has a completely different error culture
Errors are public in case of doubt,
even if you haven't done it at all.
that is certainly in the starter industry uh
completely different.
At the end of January the 1st Party Congress of the bsw.
400 members celebrate the one-person cult factor
From Galafontein.
formerly SPD and left,
now husband may also with
the wife in an attacking mood against the government,
even if the traffic lights change their title
as the "stupidest government
Europe every day anew.
the trio of infernal from Habeck,
Baerbock and Lindner.
clear,
after all,
the rockets bear the female name Iris.
so so much
Feminism must be evident in the House of Baerbock.
to yourself by criticism are always teflon-like AB
their style somewhere between allegedly.
close to the people and very black and white
feel themselves okuliste
populist.
means that i kind of uh
talk shit out of people's mouths.
I don't think people want populists,
they want to listen to politicians
and the really
also launch change,
improve life.
when you perceive me like this,
if we are perceived as such,
I would be very grateful.
So far found her
on the traditional bench or on talk show
Armchairs take place.
a separate party,
on the other hand,
does work and costs money.
in Karlsruhe treasurer takes care of
suikad and colleague raket
to receive donations.
just no money from the wrong people.
there was already bad press
for alleged transfers from Russia.
with any there are
a conspicuousness uh
a donation over 1,000 euros came from someone in,
who pretends to be Mir Putin.
so who is behind this donation as people
we can not find out uh
do not get the information from the bank.
but that is not further wild,
because we have referred this back
or have undone,
the abruhung and so catch Kam.
the money is gone again and someone has just
Fun with it.
the bsw account is well filled,
also thanks to an entrepreneurial couple
that donated 5 million euros.
otherwise,
mainly small donations come in,
some with nice messages for better policy.
n use that one
can give in such a small proof text
and there is just very much
uh encouragement uh
People uh
explain their emergency situation very briefly simply,
i am a pensioner.
am minimum I can only 3 euros
uh,
if also times uh.
Greetings to
Members of the party somehow oriented now uh.
Greetings to Sarah and Oscar.